okay yeah so i want to know as like uh a
person who also
likes his rap music um like do you want
to like give any shout outs i guess or
like or like your
influences yeah the influence is
basically like japanese or like western
rap
oh sure yeah absolutely well let me
think about it because
a lot of my favorites are definitely
under the radar i would say
who would you say is like the most
well-known ah gosh out of your favorites
hmm in terms of like a japanese rap i
wonder
hmm i feel like um
i mean i mean i think on the broader
scale of things like to a western
audience
not a lot of people know a lot of
japanese rappers right like i'd say
probably the most well-known japanese
rapper might be like shingo too
yeah yeah yeah of course who did like do
you know shingo too i don't i do not
know she knows
okay okay you know the samurai champ
blue opening oh okay
he's the guy who did all the stuff with
news basically yeah you got to explain
things to me in anime terms like it's
not an animator like everybody
he's the guy who did this yeah so he's
probably
like the most well-known in like the
western anime community maybe
but like because i don't even know a
whole lot of japanese underground rap
either right but like what about like
western rappers
uh let's see i feel like all the western
rappers that i like are very um
how do i say very obvious sort of like
um
of course yeah well of course of course
but like my
my favorite is of course eminem which is
very very the very obvious
yes and of course of course uh snoop
dogg
oh yeah i like his memes
yeah you do get some quality maymays
is that the pronunciation i thought that
that's what it was is that
what it means sorry oh okay okay
how is the right way to say it
i'm getting mixed signals here hold on
i'm sorry
[Music]
all right i think i get it memes there
you go there you go noted noted thank
you for teaching me then do you have
your do you have a favorite kelly
calliope meme wow i've seen so many of
them floating around
you hang around on like the whole life
subreddit and everything like that do
you juice oh yes i check them yeah for
sure
yeah i don't i don't react or anything
but i i'm watching i'm watching you guys
everyone on the subway is like all right
they're like get the fresh memes and
then there are plenty of them they're
like
you know